ce matin là au conservatoire de plaisir
les enfants font danser leur papa
moi qui fais souvent des stages par
enfant la plupart du temps c'est les
mères qui viennent avec leurs enfants et
aujourd'hui on a bien signalé que c'est
un atelier papa enfants la danseuse
chorégraphe venue de poitiers a préparé
toute une série de jeux pour que les
deux opus vivre de vrais moments de
partage artistique
on va pas se mettre à la barre et faire
des exercices dit de danse
en fait on va rentrer en mouvement de
façon ludique joyeuse dans le jeu ils
vont pas avoir l'impression de se mettre
dedans c'est finalement à la fin
la séance est pour s'apercevoir qu'ils
sont en danse et qui sont bien dans leur
corps en train de danser avec les corps
qu'ils ont même s'ils ne sont pas
danseur à la bohalle et on va faire ce
jeu là vous avez six d entre vous qui
est sédentaire qui est nomade
une matinée qui s'inscrit dans la
semaine pour l'égalité femmes hommes de
la ville de plaisir
histoire de rappeler que les papas aussi
peuvent passer du temps avec leurs
enfants
toute la semaine on est au boulot au
travail et nos enfants pour les
activités à côté et donc là c'est un
moment privilégié où je vois voir ce
qu'elle fait et puis elle ça lui plaît
aussi de savoir son papa viens et vois
ce qu'elle fait et partagent des moments
avec elle
c'est vrai qu'à la maison nous lance
souvent pour pour la campagne qu'en
danse avec elle à la maison donc là
c'était l'occasion de faire ça dans un
endroit avec un cadre avec une
professionnelle donc voilà c'est
l'occasion de le partager ce moment
ensemble bond ans un peu à la maison
avec elle enfin on fait un peu défaut
fouet puis avec danse avec les stars
on s'y prête donc c'est l'occasion de
faire ça ici avec avec des papas qui
font les fous fous avec leurs petites
filles et petits garçons une matinée
riche en complicité
attention cet atelier père enfants
réalisés par des amateurs
il est fortement recommandé de le
reproduire chez soi
[Musique]